they made McCleary more badass too like
he own that action scene like
occasionally you get Nick Fury shooting
a gun here and there and like a these
other Marvel films but they gave him a
full like a full-on scene was just with
him kicking ass like they took these
characters that usually feel like cameos
or something like that or throw in an
Avengers thing but they just made them
part of this world the part of the story
shield for example it wasn't like a
shield Avengers oh my god it was like it
was just the world you know it fit that
elevator scene was so fun i watch it
again like this fight is just so cool he
doesn't even use a shield when what
Captain America do in close-quarter yeah
yeah exactly and it's in such a small
space and that's what I mean like when
that action scene comes in it's intense
like and it's smart cuz Captain America
is like hmm this guy's sweating a lot
this guy kind of has his fingers against
the gun right now he's putting it
together he's like you know I know the
sup guys he's ready to dance and when
that comes in it's like it makes sense
because at that point in the movie
you're like why I've lugged all these
people is that Nick Fury now why is
everyone at shield trying to kill
Captain America yeah it's like it's so
it's intense and it's thrilling it's a
mystery like I really dug this from a
lot it's different than any of the other
Marvel films I've ever seen it's very
different I wondered if they had maybe
actually killed Nick Fury this time yeah
I did do you know they committed enough
to that where I was like maybe they're
yeah he's dead he's gone for a large
part of the movie and yeah I like this a
lot of this movies based off the fact
that he's dead
okay the whole time I was thinking like
is this how he died in the comics is
this gonna piss off fans I even thought
at one point Black Widow was gonna die
when she was going up against the Winter
Soldier I'm like on the freeway and
stuff and like the way they were doing
that I was like does she even died is
that hearing up for desert yeah and then
she got shot that went oh I really like
the romantic tease they got going on
with Captain America and Black Widow
they don't go all out it doesn't get to
that point where they're like I love you
and then they have a big kiss before
some crazy finale or some [ __ ] that
little public display of affection
scenes they had I was really cute how
she's always like go after someone else
cuz she's pushing away the guy she likes
it's a psychological thing they don't
really fit together but you get a
glimpse of of what it could be like if
they maybe did Oh
like they understand and care about each
other yeah so like that's cool I like
that you know I was enhancing you know
Black Widow this time was able to expose
herself and even though you've got I
don't really get details you're still
like well KGB she was a bad [ __ ] at one
point now she works for America yeah
sexy probably got a good badge I just
like the adjective is good as if as
opposed to like nice or cute what cute
have you ever seen a vagina and went
that is cute minor complaint not really
a complaint yeah it's not a complaint at
all I think that that's not a complaint
the Winter Soldier character [ __ ] the
Internet and everyone in the world like
was like it's buggy it's buggy
yeah you know and they reveal it as such
a late twist in the film that it was
like they probably just told us up front
there's something like that or a little
bit earlier on it makes sense makes this
restore yeah what's happenin and stuff
some of those things are just like we
some of us might know but it makes more
sense than the story to put it out there
when they did I feel like you could have
explored the character more if we knew
earlier that it was Bucky though I know
it's not the point I'm just saying we
get a lot of character exploration and I
thought it would have been cool to see
that you don't agree with me you're
gonna walk out that door cuz you're not
entitled to your own opinion yeah I like
that finale between the two where he's
like I'm not gonna fight you even though
he just kicked his ass but he had to at
the time he just starts whaling on the
Captain America space yeah painful - how
was it ahh I like the whole like Museum
thing appreciating Captain America yeah
that was really neat you know I'm like
this is you know you Captain America has
a little charm when like when kids look
at an MN and he like tells him shut your
[ __ ] mouth you know yeah he hates
children and never once oh but knowledge
to bring up a sexual commentary about
like his life in a way cuz he's like it
was that the last kiss yeah and it was
like the last kiss he's that even though
he says it wasn't that was like the last
one yeah so that makes you go as he has
it had sex and forever has he ever had
sex like in the first one think about it
he was like the short skinny guy who got
a shrimp I think you would go then he
gets buff and he doesn't hook up with
anyone and then now it's like he gets
frozen for a hundred years his sperm
count is probably really good because of
all the ice and then he
probably has to jack off a lot my mind
went down this path when I was watching
the scene he seems like the might be a
virgin though a 95 year old virgin good
for him he's gonna go to heaven you know
what I like to you about this movie what
they did with Peggy oh yeah that was
really impressive like you get the old
footage of her then it's the same
actress was this it was a different
actress right when she was like an old
person yeah no I'm talking about when
they showed the footage of her that was
yeah they got it they got it was Hayley
Atwell they got her to do the old
footage they definitely heard a
different actress to be older her that
was so [ __ ] neat and I loved that
scene with her away than like old saggy
and Captain America yes heartbreaking
yeah like last time I saw you were a
fine piece of ass now you're old and
wrinkly how much exactly what was going
through Captain America's Mike that's
how he talks he was just really horny
when he met her I just think he's really
sex the prime I mean is that I don't
think he thinks doubts why he's always
so tense she got to live her life and
everything and that moment where I guess
she has like amnesia or dementia maybe
Alzheimer's
that's what's called I work at a
doctor's office and I didn't forget who
she's talking to and she's like sees
Captain America again it's like she's
still in love with this guy yeah it's a
really heartbreaking moment he kind of
thought of like when the old lady from
Titanic if she were to see Jack the
Captain America Act in America yeah in
Robin vos it was a great move he's like
40 but really he's like five years old
or something he's gonna that thing where
you or you ain't it way too quick or
whatever maybe have that was funny he
falls in love with his teacher she's
actually not funny it's really got as
like a heart attack or something yeah
why I don't know it's a pg-13 comedy
that went down a very dark path this is
a fun light-hearted comedy and all the
sudden Jack's having a heart attack
so yeah some reasons to see you ready
for this [ __ ] it's gonna be a long list
number one
gotta love Captain America are we
including Chris Evans in that of course
we're number two I wanna say my boy
Anthony Mackie elephant Anthony Mackie
mad at the [ __ ] it was the [ __ ]
three scarlet johansson / Scott
Johnson's ass yes the two
black widow / black widow we're just a
number four is Jeremy number four uh man
dead Nick Fury's tombstone / Nick Fury
Nick you know his actual name is
Nicholas furious so if I may need me
Nicholas and my last name be furious too
fast to do furious that's Nick Fury's
favorite movie no it's very v action and
visual effects these are no serious
order you know what is this [ __ ] six six
is the story yeah writing you're writing
and directing you know that sort of
political thriller thing they got going
on they got it down pretty well seven
seven I'd have to say the score good
music eight the post-credits ting oh
yeah good post credits thing and make
credits and stuff - all right guys these
are checking out us talking about
Captain America the Winter Soldier why
don't you go ahead you scroll that
comment box below and tell us if you saw
the movie what's your favorite scene
well you haven't seen the movie geez why
did you watch to this point yeah and
then once you're done with all that
stuff come over here and then click on
stuff two episodes the reason this is
Lightyear Jerry right here for more
episodes reasons and last but not least
if you want to get updated every time
one of our videos are out subscribe I
want that shield man you know who I will
[ __ ] up with that shield a pimp like a
real pimp be like you shouldn't be doing
that to a woman unless I like his
hookers so you're only gonna beat up the
the I don't particularly care about
these women but [ __ ] you in how weird
must have you to have sex with a
prostitute